في بريطانيا يترك الاطباء الشباب من
الخريجين الجدد وظائفهم الثابته للعمل على
تيك توك ومضاعفه اجورهم وهي ازمه في وقت
تواجه الخدمات الصحيه في البلاد نقصا في
العماله واضرابات من اجل تحسين الظروف
مؤثرون رعايه الصحيه او كما يطلق عليهم في
الاعلام الغربي مدفلوانس هي ظاهره موجوده
منذ سنوات لكن ارتفعت كثيرا مع انتشار
الوباء والاغلاق المنزلي وتيك توك يرحب
بها اكثر من اي منصه اخرى في منطقه هنا
هناك الكثير جدا من تلك الحسابات وملايين
المتابعين لها ومن ان هناك العديد من
الاطباء الموثوقين الذين يرفعون الوعي حول
عادات خاطئه على حساباتهم او بتحدونا
خرافه متداوله الا ان من الصعب كشف ما اذا
كانت طبيب طبيبا حقا المحتلا يقدم معلومات
المضلله ويسعى لزياده متابعين
مذهب معكم الى الاردن سالنا الناس هناك هل
تثقون بمنشورات وحسابات الاطباء على مواقع
التواصل متابعه
اي شخص بده يسوق لاعلان الى موقع التواصل
راح يعمل لك افضل شيء بالنسبه له بفضل اني
اروح دايركت على الطبيب مش انه عن طريق
اعلان او كذا او او اسمع من اشخاص مقربين
لي عن الموضوع انه هذا فعلا هذا الطبيب
منيح او لا ههه لا الواحد لازم يتاكد من
المعلومات يعني مش ياخذ الشيء بشكل دائري
لانه خلص علوم حكي طبيب على مواقع التواصل
ايه ياخذها كامله ليه لا لازم يتاكد
يستشير الطريق بشكل شخص لانه مش كل
الشغلات بتكون بشكل عام على كل الناس لا
لازم كل شيء شخص ايه في حاله المريض انه
يتاكد من المريض من الطبيب مشاكل
يعني نتاكد منه اكثر طب بالنسبه
للمستحضرات لا لانه مستحضرات همم في اشياء
اثار جانبيه ممكن يؤثر على مريض عنده مرض
معين غير المرض اللي هو بده ياخذ لاجله
الدواء يكون عنده ضغط او سكر او شفه لازم
مراجعه طبيب او صيدلاني بالنسبه للدكاتره
اللي همم اذا كانوا موافقين وبنشروا عن
شيء معين في مواد طبيعيه ممكن تساعدني
بدون ما اروح على طبيب اه ممكن اثق فيها
اه لا في نفس الوقت بيعتها من حسب مين
الدكتور اللي عم بينشر هذا البروشه يعني
في دكاتره لهم اسمهم في السوق والناس
تعرفهم في دكاتره الناس ما بتعرفهم فجاه
مشهورين وعندهم كثير وارز ما بنعرف كيف
صارت هاي الشغل يمكن دافعين يمكن شيرين
هذا الدكتور مش لا يصلح ان يكون دكتور
[موسيقى]
في مسجد ينضم الينا من عمان دكتور نبهان
حسين طبيب الاشعه التشخيصيه والمؤثره على
مواقع التواصل اكثر من خمسه ملايين متابعه
دكتور يسعد صباحك اهلا بك اولا بدنا نسمع
تجربتك الشخصيه ما الذي يدفع دكتور مثلك
او طبيب مثلك للتوجه من العيادات
والمستشفيات الى منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم اهلا وسهلا فيكم
ومن متابعين وفي هذا البرنامج لطيف
اول شيء
كان موضوع انه نار الطبيب في وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي امر بصراحه خلينا نقول
غير مقلوب
كانت وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي هي احمد
طريقه لايصال المعلومه والوعي بالاضافه
الى التلفزيون الى المتابعين همم
انتاج الفراوله ولله الحمد
العديد من الاطباء انه بدا يكون قاعده
جماعيه
نعم انه عجبتكم الفكره
العالم يعني صار يتابع الاطباء بشكل كبير
وانه هذه التطبيقات نفسها وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي نفسها
بدات تدعم الاطباء اللي اصلا دخلوا فقط
الاطباء اللي كانوا اصلا فقط
الاطباء نفسهم كمال اكتشفوا انه انه ليش
لا طالما هو
دكتورنا اليوم سؤالي لماذا تتعرضون
لانتقادات وتحضيرات يعني عناوين المقالات
بحق اطباء السوشيال ميديا مخيفه كلها
تحذيريه كلنا تحدث عن مصطلحات ظاهره
واحضروا وهكذا كيف تردون عليهم
صحيح وانا على فكره كنت من الناس اللي
يؤيدوا هذا الكلام ولكن ليس بالاجماع وليس
بالمجمل للاسف خلينا نقول في ناس
هم لا مو انهم قد يكونوا طلاب طب مثلا فما
عندهم الخبره في اصطياد المصادر الموثوقه
خلينا نقول عرض المعلوم الصحيه بشكل جيد
او بشكل مثبت علميا في النهايه همم
المعلومات يعني لما تجمع عده مقاطع انه
هذه المعلومات اما يعني عامه جدا ولا تصلح
ابدا لان تكون معلومات طبيه او للاسف في
معلومات يعني خاطئه والمعلومه الخاطئه لما
تعطيها انت على على السوشل ميديا في
تطبيقات الناس ما يعني في ناس ما بيدوروا
صراحه في ناس ما بيدوروا عن هذه المعلومه
استغفر الله هم ياخذوا هذه المعلومه انه
صدرت من طبيب وبالتالي هي صحيحه 100% بعض
المعلومات مخيفه جدا قد تثيره في نفوس
الاهل عن الاطفال بعض المعلومات يعني قد
احنا اذا بدنا نذكر مثال عن بدون ذكر همم
زعل ونزل الدم فهو مصاب بمرض عظيم جدا
ومخيف الان هذه المعلومه يعني مغلوطه
تماما شكلها من بره لما تشوفها اوكي ابني
في الاهالي والاهالي يصيروا انه يعني
معلوم مخيفه بالنهايه قد يكون طفل مجرد
مصاب بالتهاب
الرئوي بسيط طيب دكتور همم انا كمستخدمه
لموقع التواصل الاجتماعي وانت كخبير
بالموضوع لما ادخل في ملايين حسابات في
منطقه العربيه مثلا وانا مهتمه بالمعلومات
العلميه كيف افرق بين الحسابات الموثقه
ذات مستقيه وبين الدخان على هذه الليله
سؤال ممتاز جدا
اصحاب الحسابات العلميه والصحيه كيف
تختاري ان همم او المؤثر في مجال الصحي
اللي انت انت تفضلي انك او يكون هو نوع ما
يعني موضوع الان اصحاب التطبيقات بشكل عام
بدات توفق الحسابات التي همم اصحاب
المحتوى المطلوب تمام بشكل او باثر على كل
حال بالنهايه همم مني المعلومه اللي تظلم
الطبيب
امه مؤكد 100% كل شخص انا سمعت سمعت الان
احد في المقابلات الي سجلتوها يقول
المعلومه لا تصبح على كل الاجسام ولا
تصلحوا على كل البشر تمام جسدي غير البيت
فالصحه التي قد معلومه اللي انا اقولها قد
تكون على اغلب البشر على اغلب الناس في
الصحه ماشي صحيحه ومثبته علميا ولكن لا
تصير ما ما بتقدر ترقيها على كل الاجسام
على كل البشر وعلى كل الصفحه لذلك يفضل
انا يعني اذا تسمحوا لي ارسل رساله الى
اصحاب المحتوى انه قبل ان ينزل معلومه انه
يتاكد من مصادر بشكل كامل معلش يتعب على
المعلومه شويه لانه في النهايه
بس انا عندي سؤال هل صحيح وهل فعلا انه
دخلك على تيك توك اكثر من دخلك طبيب في
عياده
الان تطبيق تكتب يعني كتب لا صراحه ولكن
استوشل ميديا كل قيم دول بشكل عام اه نعم
لان ااا يعني ما بدنا ندخل بالتفاصيل ولكن
الله يبارك لك ويبارك لنا كمان شكرا لك
طبيب المفروض يكون مهتم في الموضوع في
مواضيع اخرى ولكن لما يكون طبيعي
على السوشيال ميديا هذه اصلا بتفيده في
الحياه الصحيه في الحياه المهنيه في
الحياه الواقعيه
شكرا لك دكتور نبهان حسين طبيب الاشعه
التشخيصيه ومؤثر على مواقع التواصل باكثر
من خمس مليون متابع